hello my name is Rocco and hi my name is
Shawn Sharon I'm a software engineer
with Holton research today we'll be
talking about import-export and updates
to various formats such as archive
related formats DICOM and email related
formats will also give a sneak peak of
some of the new import-export utilities
for registering your own formats alright
it's actually half-past four so why
don't I begin hello everyone my name is
Rafa and today I will be talking about
library link utilities so about library
link and extending it in C++ right so I
try to make it very clear in the
abstract for this chocolate
unfortunately I will require a basic
experience with library link from all of
you this is because you know I'm time
limited so there is no enough time to
cover library link basics so if you
don't know what library link is or you
haven't EC + + before then and this talk
might be a little bit hard to follow but
anyway let's do a very very brief
introduction so as you know we have
plenty of programming languages in the
world and of course the more firm
languages in the center of the universe
and in each of these languages there
plenty important libraries that are
widely used and of course we would like
to harness the power of those libraries
in whorfin language without rewriting
them directly know from language right
so so what can we do yeah we have
developed a number of frameworks that
allows us to link those libraries into
the Wolfram language for example for for
Java we have J link for Python there is
external evaluator I'm sure there and
there were some talks in this conference
already about external evaluate and
stock will of course focus on the
library link all right so as you know
let's say we have a wall from desktop
instance running another computer and we
have a shirt see library somewhere on
our system that we would like to link to
the wall from language to be able to use
the functions from the library and this
is where a library link comes in handy
it's written in C so we have a C library
it all fits nicely so basically if I
were to summarize the library link in
one slide then it's all about exchanging
the data between more from language and
and they see library right so we have
plenty of different kinds of expressions
in the Wolfram language and then if we
have a seal I breathe and usually there
are some specific types defined in this
library so what we can do if library
link is that we can take those from
language expressions and library link
will give us some corresponding C types
and then we just need a little bit of
creativity to make it work with the
external library types right so this is
library link if we have a C library we
are all good to go but then it turns out
we can have a library written in C++ and
as you can see in the picture it's not a
perfect fit here right so what we did is
that we wrote this extra layer around
library link it's called library' link
utilities or i love you and basically it
provides a c++ interface to two
librarian functionality and in some ways
it also extends it alright so yes how
can you get the view how can you use it
right now unfortunately you can
unless you work it well from and I have
to apologize here the original plan was
to have this released on github before
the conference unfortunately there are
still some issues we need to address and
win to publish the documentation so I'm
working hard to to make this happen soon
I can't give you any exact dates but to
convince you that this is not a scam and
this actually exists here is a
screenshot from the current working
graph of the documentation as you can
see it's divided into modules and in
this module you will have a tutorial
like introduction with some examples and
then and the detailed API reference will
follow so this is generated based on the
oxygen comments within the source code
ok so and this this actually exists
of course it's if it was released on
github already then this stock would
make a bit more sense but still so now I
will go over a major features of library
link and then for each one I will tell
you what has what is different in in llu
in this aspect so let's start with data
containers so today in the morning there
was a nice talk about numeric array so I
would just very quickly show you what I
have here so of course numeric array is
an array of numeric data of specific
type here I can create a numeric array
of of dimensions thousand by thousand
with random integers each one being
64-bit integer and I have this nice
summary box so this expression occupies
eight megabytes right because there's
eight bytes per per integer but now if I
notice that all the numbers are between
minus thousand and 1000 and they will
fit into a 16-bit integer I can
basically contain the same amount of
information with only two megabytes
right and there are 12 supported types
so yeah so this is numeric are in the
Wolfram language so if you want to send
it over library link what you get in in
the C code is a structure called M
numeric array right and then there is
also M tensor which existed before it
corresponds to the PAC terrain or from
language and it only supports free and
data types so basically my
recommendation is to use the numeric
array whenever possible okay so we also
we can also send images over library
link let's take a simple image it has a
datatype and some metadata and so for
example color space I'm sorry if you can
I can see but there is color space image
dimensions channels etc so if you send
this image no the library link what you
get in in C is the M image structure
which contains both the pixel values and
also the metadata and we also have
sparse array type so if you have a large
array with only a few elements being
different than than 0 or some different
than some predefined value then you
should use sparse array so if you see
that dimensions here are very large but
it only takes up nine kilobytes
yes so this is also available in in
library link ok so what all those types
have in common is the similar API don't
worry if you can't read this this is
just to show me that in library link you
get a structure with function pointers
right so here is an example for numeric
array yes so if you want to do an
operation the m numeric array you need
to choose a proper function and access
it the eye pointer in this structure ok
and some of the functions also return an
error code
which is usually just a boolean
information if I never happened or not
okay so this is a C API and then the C
code it works great but when you program
in C++ you may expect something a little
bit different so what we didn't tell you
is that each container is a proper class
and there is a hierarchy of classes and
we try to divide the responsibilities
between different classes so this is a
simple inheritance graph for for a
numeric array right and also we added
some convenient constructors to into the
containers in a little use so in this
example I create a four elements vector
this is a vector from the standard
library so if I want to create a tensor
for example of the same contents I can
pass a vector dialect directly to the
constructor or maybe so this will give
me a flat tensor right but if I want
different dimensions I can for example
pass a pair of iterators to the transfer
constructor and then the desired
dimensions and this will give me a
tensor two by two all right so it's
quite convenient to construct and these
containers ok what else do we have
we tried to make the interface
forever.you containers similar to and
the standard library containers so we
have this begin and end methods that
will give you iterators yourself square
bracket operator for accessing
particular elements of the container and
what this means is that you can easily
use the alario containers in India
algorithms from the standard library
alright so in this example I want to get
the mean value of all elements in the
numeric array so I put the numeric array
here to be stood accumulate and I will
give the total numbers and I just need
to divide by the size all right so this
is quite convenient
so moving on another important
part of well writing code in general is
error handling so in library link which
is written in C we have the usual method
of error handling in C which is error
codes if you remember the signature that
all library link functions have to
follow they return an integer right
which is supposed to be the error code
and there are eight predefined values
okay of course you can read you can
return a different value and I think it
will be reported as a user error roof
with the code that you that you returned
so let's see this in in action here I'm
loading an encode string method from the
demo string library it's supposed to
implement a Caesar cipher yes so it's a
shift cipher and for example if I am
passed a string ABCDE F and I want to
shift by two positions i get c d e f g h
ok that's good so now let's try a
different string with negative shift why
not and now we get the library function
error but it's not easy to tell what is
exactly wrong here maybe the string or
maybe negative shift is not supported so
what do we have in ll u to address this
first of all in other you the error
handling is based on exceptions right we
have a class for this it's called error
manager and if you have a code that
wants to use mm some exceptions and if
you want those exceptions to be
propagated to the Wolfram language if
they are thrown in your in your code
then you have to register them first so
you give it each exception must have a
short name and then message and this
message may contain template slots that
will be populated at runtime with actual
values so in this example I I registered
to two exceptions and how do you use
them in your code when when you want to
throw instead of using the keyword throw
bless you you're just called fro
exception you say which one and then you
have to provide values for those
template slots
okay so let's see how this works I have
written a very simple parklet for this
presentation and I have implemented the
encode string methods which is supposed
to do exactly the same thing but you
said are you so let's pass this weird
string and the negative shift so what I
get now is a failure object and you can
read this but it says negative 2/5 minus
T is not supported so now I know exactly
what is wrong so I can choose a positive
shift as a second argument so now I see
that the input string must contain only
letters from the English alphabet okay
so if I fix this as well I get something
that works right so thanks okay so
that's handy
well when you at the point when you
throw this exception you have to provide
a value for this template slot and well
yeah this is handled by the llu yes yes
ok so let's move on ok so as you know
labelling also supports wst P which is
formerly known as math link in that case
you need to choose a different signature
for your labelling function the one that
takes all from library data and ambling
or WS link as well let's see a simple
example when you load such function well
from language you have to pass link
objectives the input argument type and
output argument type so if we reverse
library link string of course we get
nearly our bill all right so it's just
by building so this is a how an
implementation of this function may look
like in C if you notice we have we have
to handle the memory manual you right so
if something wrong happens in each of
this function then we need to release
the string and also notice that the type
of data that we get from the link is
encoded in the function name right and I
mean in C this is perfectly fine this is
a you would seek out but again when we
program in C++ we may expect something
else so what happens in a value is that
there is an and there is this ml stream
class that wraps over the m link and it
overloads the stream operators so we
also provide support for popular c++
types for example here i have a nested
map with string keys on the first level
and the integer keys on the second level
so is it difficult to send this over
allow you to the world frame language
apparently you just need to have an
instance of the ml stream and call the
the stream operator on your map so this
will be automatically translated to the
association in the world from language
and of course it wouldn't be of much use
if you couldn't do it with your custom
classes so here I have a color structure
with three three free channels right so
how do I send it over math link to two
from language then I need to just
overload the stream operator for my type
right so I say whenever I send something
of type color and then interpret it as
an RGB color expression and then the
channels follow
so if I have my extreme instance and I
passed this color object this will be
received as an RGB color in the wall
from language and we also provide a
number of classes for common types of of
expressions to make working with the
same extreme class easier alright what
else do we have in a level you so this
is having not present in every link at
all but in other you can issue some
debug messages some logs directly to
your notebook right because of course
you can always print to print something
to your console but you can also write
messages to the notebook there are three
severity levels error warning and debug
and let's take a look at a simple
function so I have made the calls to our
login functions bold so the first line
here
I want to issue a debug message about
number of arguments so the arguments to
this univac is comma separated list of
values and then they will be just
concatenated into a string and here for
example if some condition is met then I
see a warning and if there was an
exception from then my issue an error
message so this is just a simple example
don't pay attention to the rest of this
code and actually let me load this
function here okay so what happens if I
ran this function with these arguments I
get a debug message and the result yeah
sorry this is so small I don't know why
it doesn't scale but it says the library
function enter the five arguments anyway
let's move also with a different set of
input arguments I got a warning so if
you know this this gives you the exact
place in the source code that the
message was issued from and the function
name and let's try a different set of
arguments
okay this time I got an error and the
failure object right so here you have a
lot of possibilities to customize this
for example we have predefined settings
to get some more concise logs this time
the log is in the form of a and just row
of strings okay
similarly here and if you don't want to
get all the messages in your notebook
you can print them easily to the
messages window so again this is a
predefined setting you just need to set
this function selector to it so now I
don't see anything in the notebook just
the result but probably when I open the
messages window yes I get my my logs
okay okay all right so let's switch it
back and the last thing you can also
filter the log messages for example by
the severity level if I only want to see
warnings I do this and and I just see
warnings right started switching back
again okay so that's logging okay so I
can do one more thing we also have added
a few functions to to be able to monitor
progress of your library link functions
right so in in plain library link there
is a function aboard Q which you can
call to check if the user requested to
abort the current computation if I'm not
mistaken it returns a boolean value and
well you can basically ignore it but so
what we did in Lu is that we have this
class we function checkerboard it of
course it's called the the library link
function aboard Q but in case if there
was an abort requested then it will
throw an exception which is much more
difficult to ignore right
of course you can do it if you if you
really try hard but let's hope someone
during doing the code review
notice this alright and progress monitor
can also do something else it maintains
a number between zero and one which is
shared between your library in the
kernel and for example if you have found
a long computation in a loop you can
increase the value of progress using the
increment operator of course there are
some options to customize this but we
don't have time to cover all of them and
yes let's see how this works
so notice that this time I'm loading a
function from my demo library and I
specify the progress monitor should be
handled by this symbol yes you have to
pass a simple as an option and okay well
progress bar is a simple helper function
that I wrote which takes this number
between 0 and 1 and it turns it into a
proper progress bar so it's nothing
really complicated so here I will call
the library function with argument 5 so
what I see is a progress bar and then I
get the result right and then when I try
something different ok of course we
won't wait until it finishes I can just
abort it in the usual way write comment
dot for example so this is aborted and
unfortunately I have to abort my talk as
well I had one no sorry
had one more topping but we won't cover
this I'm afraid so let me just skip to
some resources if you're interested in
the library link in general you should
definitely read the tutorials also in a
few weeks check and check the Wolfram
research github account hopefully we'll
find a user
ok so I think that's that's all
are there any questions